we might not be getting just one star
game movie we might be getting a trilogy
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv movie
channel
so in my last video please go back and
check it i talked about how amazon might
be considering to do in a hard reboot of
the stargate franchise now that is
a hard reboot basically means
the universe didn't exist they could
just start again new characters new
actors knew everything and they don't
have to worry about the canon from the
original series and the original film
now this was a plan that actually dean
devlin and roland emerick that wrote and
directed the original stargate movie
from 1994
and came up with at the time so
originally in 1994 it the movie was
always supposed to be a trilogy and then
in 2016 they pitched that again to mgm
and there was briefly a deal between mgm
and warner brothers to make this trilogy
that was going to be a hard reboot
amazon seemed to be dusting those plans
off
so let's have a look at what we know
so
if they go ahead with this plan the
first film will basically be a reboot of
the original stargate movie i imagine
the storyline will be slightly different
we'll be seeing different gold they'll
do a star trek thing with this
and like the klingons that you know the
google will look mental
and probably and they will basically
remake that first movie the whole idea
of that first film is supposed to be
still based around the egyptian
mythology
now the second
movie and we have a working title for
because they were initially going in
2016 to just make a sequel to the
original star game film and apparently
kurt russell and james spader were both
interested
the plan now would be to be a complete
reboot of the entire trilogy but back in
2016 this was the plan they were going
to do a sequel
that sequel is going to be called first
gods
now that is the working title so what
can we surmise from that because i don't
know any more than that i know that the
working title but what can we surmise
from that well the first gods for me if
we're looking at um our own history
would probably be based around the
sumerian gods to anunnaki
now the anunnaki
is very popular in ancient alien theory
they are considered to be the first gods
sumerian texts and on the writing in
this area at the time was some of the
first actually pretty much the first
writing we've ever seen it was the first
organized culture and it seems to have
been the first organized religion we
know about
so what is the annunaki well for one i
should actually say the annunaki and the
nephilim actually do appear in the bible
they're considered to be fallen angels
in the bible um
and we all know what they say what
ancient aliens theories say about fallen
angels that they're really aliens and
actually if you swap the word god for
alien the bible all of a sudden makes a
lot more sense so in the ancient alien
version of the anunnaki um then
inaccurate alien race from the planet
nibiru
they came to earth and actually found
primitive human beings um
cavemen basically
and turned them into a more intelligent
species they turned them into homo
sapiens they turned them into us they
pre-programmed us to love gold
and we actually
dig all the gold up and make watches and
things out of it not because um it's
valuable to us but because we're
programmed to think it's valuable
because the anunnaki need it and when
the annunaki return
they're going to basically make us all
empty our jewelry boxes out
it's very simplified version of that
story but you get the hint so the
anunnaki live on the planet nibiru which
is
sometimes an alien
planet from you know light years away
but sometimes considered to be actually
a planet within our solar system and i
think that would make sense for what
they're planning for the second movie so
first movie egyptians second movie
anunnaki and based on sumerian texts and
then a third movie that'll bring it all
together
amazon could make these three movies
with some very small changes
that doesn't destroy canon and that we
could then see a tv series that just
continue the sg-1 stargate atlantis
stories and we can stay within this
universe
all
that amazon has to do is make these
three movies off world
don't base them on earth we know there's
a galaxy full of humans out there this
could be very easily done
we could create these three films along
these storylines
one egyptian one sumerian one that
brings it all together just don't set it
on earth
don't
throw the baby out with the bath water
don't piss all over cannon
do it off earth
have these movies influence what happens
on earth in this tv series but you never
connect the two they can be separate
still now that would allow amazon to
then make a big budget big hollywood big
hollywood stars movie
they could have actors in this film that
they would never be able to get in the
tv series and that is one consideration
these executives make you know they're
not disney plus they're not
the marvel universe they are going to
struggle to even get their lesser
characters into a tv series
particularly a tv series that would then
repeat a year on you
so
don't try
but also don't deny every gator out
there and do a hard reboot
you know we don't like it you know it
winds up and it almost never works
battlestar galacto is probably the only
example of a hard reboot that's ever
been successful and ever worked but the
main reason for that was there was 40
years maybe 30 years between balazar
galactica and the reboot
there's only been
now
roland denmark said there's 20 years 25
years now between the original stargate
movie in 1994 and the new movie and it's
nearly 30 years
but sg-1 has only been gone 15 years
there's not a big gap there
you know we could have a continuation of
the story very easily it doesn't need to
be rebooted and it's not like as well
say something like um
flash gordon where they would made a
movie um in 1980 and that's quite dated
at the time you know it's
a reboot wouldn't hurt that really that
franchise because it's been it's been 40
years since the original the original
was quite dated in in the time it's very
very 1980s movie
um it wasn't made with the biggest
budget in the world so a reboot could
work
i actually think highlanders another
film is desperate for a reboot but sg-1
and stargate doesn't fall into that
category
the material we have of stargate still
stands up today the 1994 movie still
looks good today the tv series still
looks good today in fact it's one of
amazon's highest rated sci-fi shows on
amazon prime at the moment
it doesn't need to be redone so don't
the fans don't want it so don't do it
so please go on to my twitter page the
link is in the description
bring back stargate make your voice
heard
put in the comments
do tweets
make your opinion heard
go onto my facebook channel do the same
put a comment on this video share this
video
we need to get this out there and we
need to get it heard as quickly as
possible because i don't want this
i want these movies but i do not want a
hard reboot i do not want dean devlin
and roland denmark to do what they want
on this movie because
they are only loyal to the original
stargate film and they think they want
they want to basically ignore the tv
series
we need to support brad wright on this
who does seem to make a lot of noise
himself trying to get amazon to listen
and trying to get amazon to make the
project he's developed with mgm
let's get out there let's support him
make as much noise as you can gators
otherwise amazon are going to do
whatever the hell they like
and they're not going to consider our
wants they're going to think they know
what we want
let's make sure we tell them loudly that
we don't want a hard reboot
like thanks guys if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification do all those button
pushing things you got to do and like
say please join the channel if you can
it really helps me to create new content
and you will get all these videos 24
hours before everybody else
so thanks very much please stay safe and
i will see you next time
wow